c'est le bicentenaire de la mort de
napoléon alors tout le monde en parle
c'est au jt de 13h et 20h j'étais même
de deux heures qui était 14h c'est
partout et spécialiste de napoléon
oui et il joue avec lakhdar a mené un
chapeau là oui oui ça c'est une blague
je venais de faire plaisir
c'est la première fois que j'amène ce
chapeau sur un plateau s'est passé au
japon ce chapeau a été commandée par
napoléon à poux par son chapelier en
1805 et il a servi jusqu'à la bataille
d'essling en mai 1809 et il a offert au
général bouton c'est une des trois ou
quatre chapeaux de la peau leur en mains
privées et je voulais faire très plaisir
parce que je n'ai jamais à mener il est
toujours resté au palais vivienne ça
c'est un truc de fou c'est mon ami tu
vas à soutenir depuis toutes ces années
ça me faisait plaisir plaisir
[Rires]
maria et ben écoute tu es sûr à la
légion d'honneur de napoléon 6 juin
ouais bah oui quand même avec ça
la chaîne est achète toutes les maisons
de me trouve que c'est pas de la tarte
de fouras est bichonné il est d'accord
justement on va faire un petit truc
connaissez-vous bien napoléon napoléon
chalencon ou les deux son clip c'est de
sortir déguisé incognito dans paris
napoléon chalencon les données devaient
de l'or c'est napoléon et pâques qui se
déguisait pour sortir napoléon oui tout
à fait il se mettait en frac de
bourgeois est il allé voir les
institutions ou les marchands et ils
allaient de me réclamer les factures que
flux pour voir si je faisais pas
arnaquer ouais donc tirer il s'habillait
assez fréquemment bourgeois et il
mettait un haut de forme alors qu'il ne
fait jamais d'autres formes est allé
voir les et comment personne leur
connaissait une personne ne
reconnaissais sais où tu sais ça c'est
vrai il est très fort cela il faut
qu'ils fassent patron incognito
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire ils
adorent manger avec les doigts napoléon
chalencon les deux napoléon c'est un peu
les deux vous avez mangé très salma a
oui j'adore ouais en fait quand je me
couche je mange à l'efs
mais j'adore le couscous ça c'est quand
tu dis
[Rires]
c'est ma faim d'ailleurs j'en ai mangé
hier soir alors non mais il paraît que
napoléon manger très salma oui parce
qu'en fait il avait fait ses études au
collège militaire dans les collèges
militaire on n'apprenait pas les bonnes
manières forcément et à l'époque c'était
des plats en sauce donc il aimait bien
manger comme ça et ça c'est dit ce seuil
et s'essuyer les mains sûres c est
surtout sur ses fauteuils en soi pour
sakhir faisaient tous les fauteuils en
soi assez régulièrement
il mangeait comme les femmes voilà il
saute et les femmes par alors justement
il est connu pour avoir accueilli tout
riquiqui napoléon chalencon les deux
salles en chalencon la peau les os la
rumeur disait qu'il avait un tout petit
zizi oui
isabelle sais que c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai c'est qu'on n'est pas dans
soirée doit viser killer un petit
teasing écoutent oui à son autopsie
contient ils sont au top si lé docteur
antomarchi et y en a on a mesuré le sexe
de l'empereur n'était pas énorme mais
bon 3,1 me santi même pas réussi mais
bon après on n'était pas là vers l'acte
il paraît qu'il était seraient entre 7
et à 10 cm j'étais là voilà un mur à mur
a par contre été très bien gaulée on
veut je m'en fous je n'ai pas connu non
mais c'est vrai on aurait pu dire de lui
dehors il affichait michel mr chez les
arbitres paraît que les gens disaient
dehors il avait la force d'un aigle met
dedans il avait un petit oiseau village
et il fait toujours le rôle ou avec ses
potes en passant son temps à les pincer
napoléon chalencon les deux pareils la
police ouais et les grognards haussier
10 et les oreilles adoré pincer les
oreilles surtout à ses grognards
c'était un signe d'affection il faisait
ça aussi à l iep les hommes s'étaient
les oreilles et les femmes c'est à wayne
est il part alors est-ce qu'il était
mort par un chien pendant qu'il faisait
trop crac boum badaboum
c'est vrai ça oui tout à fait avec
joséphine joséphine avait des petits
carlingue comme marie-antoinette c'est
des petits chiens qui sont assez rares
mieux et un jour bonaparte c'était
bonaparte il était dense dans le lit il
y avait des carlins il ya un des carlins
qui lui a mordu le mollet aya dufferin
et pas de prise il paraît que pour sa
première relation sexuelle d'apollon il
a eu avec une professionnelle
oui tout à fait ballet royal ouais c'est
vrai il paraît d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que j'habite pas loin du ballet royal 18
ans oui à peine 18 ans il venait d'avoir
18 tu sais que le palais royal perd un
endroit aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
la rue saint-denis enfin mais non ça
suffit plus vraiment mais au bois de
boulogne
mais à l'époque c'était le palais royal
c'était là où il y avait tout c'est jean
dame d'un certain style qui faisait leur
métier et on monte dans les étages
c'était très connu pour être alors l'un
possède une mèche de cheveux de l'autre
napoléon chalencon cheveux de napoléon
j'en ai plusieurs mois ah oui j'ai la
plus grosse touffe d'ailleurs non elle
adore la plus grosse teuf s'est pas
laissée passer plus de non non c'est
vrai quoi il avait une mèche ça coûte
cher ça celle-là oui particulier encore
commencé que c'est napoléon flammes je
suis dit que c'était grave pour avoir
les cheveux de chalencon bas et napoléon
n'avait pas autant chez avec moi et en
fait on vous connaît ses cheveux parce
qu'ils étaient ruiz était très fin et en
fait c'est la provenance il avait les
cheveux fins lui le cheveu très
fallacieux de 400 à 600 il est très
impulsif et part au quart de tour quand
on le chauffe est ce que c'est napoléon
chalon sous les 2 il avait le même type
que n'est pas que moi et
il paraît qu'il est effectivement ça ils
étaient ils étaient oui et sucé c'était
un nerveux bac il est petit tu étais pas
d'insultés grand mais il était petit il
était petit ahmed 68,6 ouais ce qui
mesurent aujourd'hui que mesure est à
peu près souffrait à 77,78 d'accord mais
n'étaient pas supprimées par rapport à
ses maréchaux h un rapport à sa garde
impériale il faisait 1 m 80 au garrot
oui et puis plusieurs combien 1 m 119 et
bat aurait pu faire partie de la gare de
laon presse et voilà c'est vrai
exactement ce qu'ils voulaient pas
d'être aux grands noms précis pour son
ministre le maréchal élève à 1 mètre 90
murat faisait 2 mètres alors plus les
bottes bien sûr tous les murailles était
créé rend alors je sais je l'avais
acheté au basket je la laisse passer
on